another big night for ccsd weeks after
the board voted to fire superintendent
dr jesus tonight trustees could
reconsider that move as dr jarr's
lawyers have cited a hostile work
environment within the district we do
have team coverage for you tonight kate
houston looking at the future of the
district but we start with sasha loftis
who's going to be inside tonight's
meeting sasha
denise and brian after weeks of
contention ccsd trustees will discuss
whether to reconsider that recent firing
of dr super or superintendent rather dr
jesus jarana that was decided just a few
weeks ago in a four to three vote now
today's agenda item was requested by
trustee irene cepeda who originally cast
the swing vote to terminate jarrah's
contract also tonight a potential
investigation and selection of an
outside expert to look into allegations
of a hostile work environment made by dr
jarrah's attorneys in a letter sent to
ccsd board president linda cavazos spoke
out earlier this week saying she hopes
tonight tonight's meeting remains civil
i'm feeling hopeful
that we can go through our agenda that
we can have good discussions and that we
can look at a path forward
for being more cohesive and more
collaborative for the good of our
district and our students
now discussion of an appointment of an
interim superintendent is also on the
agenda for tonight as dr jarrah's last
day is set for december 1st but of
course that is set to change depending
on what happens tonight with those other
agenda items now in that letter from dr
jarrah's attorneys tomorrow is cited as
a deadline for the district to respond
to those allegations of a hostile work
environment or attorneys will quote
presume ccsd is not interested in
resolving the matter and proceed
according it now make sure to stay with
us both on air on and online as this
meeting continues tonight reporting live
sasha loftis live local now